you uh at that event at the white house
that i mentioned at the start of the
pandemic
you you said that donald trump was quote
chosen by god
how how did god reveal to you that that
he had chosen trump
well it was a bunch of divine
appointments for me i had a dream in the
spring of 2015 that i'd be meeting
donald trump and i'm going why would i
want to meet donald trump and all of a
sudden
he comes down the escalator running for
president then i had
if you in my book i i explain all this i
i actually
to the national prayer breakfast in
early 2016 and when ben carson was still
running for office
and i was picked out of 12 people out of
the whole prayer breakfast with
thousands there
to pray out of to with uh ben carson in
a room
and um just these things kept happening
to me
and it was like building up and i'm
going this all has to mean something and
uh it wouldn't mean that i just end up
going golfing with donald trump or
something
and uh like there was so many divine
appointments that led up to that
and then uh i just uh it was something
different something that you know
because i had met him
i just know this had to all these things
that happen
i look at the to know that god exists i
use mathematics and say if you have a
one in a million happen or a one in a
billion
or this thing or this thing happens that
could never happen
when do you add them together and
consider a miracle and that's what kept
happening to me and i'm going
i go this he's been picked he's been
chosen for such a time as this wow so if
i hear you correctly you're saying
what others might see as odds and
probability
you see as divine appointment absolutely
wow if you look at it especially when
there's more than one and then there's
confirmations of that
wow you know here's a guy for me being
just an ex-addict from minnesota
a guy very functioning attic you know
growing up
and uh and here i end up in the i end up
in the white house i'll tell you an
example
so i end up in the white house uh at a
round table event
i never thought i could come within a
hundred yards of the white house with
my pal i see i see i see i see and here
i
here i end up in the white house i said
who's sitting here and they go
the president is there's like 15 of us
in the room first time i was in the
white house and
and uh they do that we go on national tv
then it's just him and i facing forward
and uh it went viral that that
screenshot and
all my friends are going what is this x
crack addict sitting next to the
president united states
jesus is real because this could not
happen this makes no sense right in
other words it's almost like
mike lindell pillow guy being at the
white house
makes such little sense it must be
divine intervention
uh absolutely absolutely it is it's just
like when i spoke at the rose garden
there when we
when i went there uh uh when we did
start making mass we had got a i got a
uh
a letter from the white house saying
would you come in and